I am following on thirds these videos
student talking through the baby I need
a new I hope according to things of
counties that Aikido the internal
martial art will that means well for a
long time that like really the baby
everything comes recall should apply and
shoulder strength
Bobby strength it is cutting the sword
happen for so some of the moves done
from very strong whole idea is to build
a power and the correct angle correctly
okay okay so that gives the foundation
idea idea it could be translated way
I'll be the spirit via to harmonize your
own body movements first like people but
move natural opiates or relearn how to
breathe so we notice movements support
moving with power all the time not just
jumping back so for words not mine
doing an aerobic wall because the
movement is quite linear really Fargo
step forward here I keep the weight back
on this way I'll tell you that I'm not
going to be went down for and I turn
this foot you down now it's like set
hands over feet okay so you're sexy
here with
so Olivia the baguette now that we did
skip forward now the reason stated
missing quite Celia from yo and from
cookie so maybe shown you if I am all in
here so so certainly fault already
people weight forward bring down like
really my shift here and a way
transferred back do be out here I love
the open G vicinity so keep your weight
forward
yeah moving with his town sort of turn
the hips here wait Huntley bowling right
here right with a bit of power yeah not
maqam elf and if you anger quite enough
they if you slightly about I keep this
quite forward and into going out my
allows Luke finish with power wait the
here go ish fine boy back here
boiling on the front milk blocked by
myself on own body simply keeping awake
ordered this clear body so when I go
through throw everything works nicely
just to thousands of why you should work
on the factor backing up to bit of a
warm up
sign here so it's going to hold with
full power grip so I can't easily making
it so I need to move away that online
fighting for D and Vantage negative
first time you use the five back to type
movement on half booth over here
Gardasil so he'll have two shots is the
shape is on here
it's the in the front center I'm going
to go to so so it's really shaping a you
step into so a blessing falling down
it's my hand forcing orbiting around my
hand letting round here phone Android
what a Pope and they dance yeah old
moving same thing right Laurie 55 funny
initiate the move was trying to school
things like block you got to spread down
and hit look like holds all any learning
this you can't move your arms apart back
off they should different technique and
integration to prepare so just to hand
it's quite a pretty strong man it sums
you up Springs with it at least drop
silver that's true that one the drop is
always mechanically very strong move so
I drop my on the hips so the gap up let
behind was sleepy another brief oh Penn
State bounce
push force roughly from the leg here you
pull me over hole they fight it stronger
than me okay so if you look at some
thank me rolls they can file these roles
from like a kneeling posture I'm not
going to show you going to show stand so
studying Aikido posture your arms
naturally form wheel in this should be
unbendable arm except shouldering taking
bad form I want to comment straight
angle here on to roll slightly of active
so follow the lines and line and going
to use both hands forward in rock next
now when I do the point bring this hand
down here feel good generally slows you
down I don't like to do that external
load is ja'kayden your please carry
quite heavy so it makes sense to learner
slow quite slow roll rods things up for
and then once you have the technique of
this you can speed it up I could show
you this pretty slow all you need to
really do is allow yourself to drop
forward here bring the back leg off the
ground at some point gravity all the
little agents they go so I just come
down here
gravity will bring down that's very easy
way learning the role non slitting
gravity drop me for the role
rosy drops you into the role and then
coming up try not to get home although
the book me on the ground I can ask you
to show you doing this
not that I'm already slowly then getting
up fast it reformer the back of role is
really essentially same there other ones
we vertically are but all would roll
back the drama of manner poor girl II
overall backward roll thanks same
posture that's a bit trip yet because
they sort of over so my knee will line
up this leg I drop down here ok now
again I we when we put it on the ground
to go there so I was more doing it I
can't do this B to tell you that is
leading this is forward and then as
gravitation down all these points wrong
things to order throwing yourself
backwards flapping it back yeah
lots variation eyeballs highways their
transfer light
okay so in this training frightful do
not trade to form my soft map you should
be think about falling elsewhere hard
verses are being thrown on concrete
floors iPhones and techniques you need
is slightly different so what my lady
that you can get away with on the
softmax and different sort what you need
on a hard floor your genital bony points
on your body rolling on the hard floor
you hit elbows ankle joints that kind
stuff get those down you will know if
you used to do is hard
slapping on a soft mat if you do that on
concrete from the high for once
originally and the chakras are up your
arm okay I know that's a personal
experience so you should try and develop
your rolling so it works hard surface
soft so just the shoe just could be
rolling them okay so first in same thing
will do on the mat doesn t make any
difference you will be sleepy bodega
life okay so so difference in what I do
here or there despair letting mind when
you're training to be very cool okay
okay silicates white traded the - I told
it's not that difficult but mostly the
confidence so these many train grateful
expect on priests yourself too far you
donor scared of with itself you will see
that our weight training trifle is to
pass on you support you here a high fall
fishes savers of forward roll here it's
more sideways a beautiful support most
is quite alone here keep your head up
force of the bring yourself around I can
focus just alone center again I can do
this
slow gravity drop so once the lines up
drop here at some point on sky over now
notice the foot it's vertical this is
really full if you take a hard fall here
and you flip it this way
this leg can come down now you either
kick your opposite leg or you will crush
your chin jiggles so you both legs again
this stop happy leave you don't do
especially second once why okay so
[Music]
just slow drop gravity does everything
yet growth is your friends compared to
the map will you do under control
that's fine yet so it's very good drop
into that left foot
it's to think of it being pad yeah
did you actually get your paper nothing
has been thrown generally Tommy's trying
to using a medium good amount power
detective invert you ride that power
those is let's kind of energy himself
you can any speed stuff really wanted
you try to it's like the kind of kick
over head device is from answers spring
so it is more spring and then just
launched straight good okay going to
practice from more of a tribal on
non-real product to take a hand knows I
like an cohesion I'm not always high and
II enjoy it safe lonely and so this
allows a whole difference poor give you
say that completely very robust makes
down follow there we go breezy they're
here don't go faster need a lot are not
supplying it have to be doing with it
but the feel of ambulance
pork sauce a nice to build up up
the heat heavy line that handles
promotion drug to boot okay okay to look
that first by Eastern anko and wrote
sorry Akiko you making fools and 1/4
mile time for fighting but these
remember this the size of and he wrote
directly home I ain't going that is from
the foundations like you know you are as
far as quite logical spell as I
understand see their use of the week box
so everything you do Jill the same with
your tart when you're learning you try
and see the connection between technique
so revenge all the things become one
technique that may not make a little
things just pounding away drinking while
really this idea that's quite simple
some of these being calm so the approach
taken on say we might die that's not
this really way I did it is to try and
get the woman's body and the connection
to our narrative work easy heart center
the control you through the center if
you're giving pain through a pain
technique just rely on the pain if
you'll so being show me your second what
you get your nominees prizes include
react as you say so beginning you start
pretty good people view others these
frustrating people more detail
Georgey
[Music]
you